[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur LCP pour
une émission spéciale consacrée à la
commission mixte paritaire sur le projet
de loi immigration se députés et se
sénateurs sont réunis depuis 17h pour
tenter de trouver un compromis sur le
texte alors il n'y a toujours pas de
fumée blanche la séance est même
suspendue juste jusqu'à 21h à la demande
des républicains le suspense c'est donc
à son comble quant à un accord car il
faut rapprocher les points de vue de la
majorité et des républicains
majoritaires dans cette commission alors
pour nous accompagner décrypter cette
actualité parlementaire nous serons en
duplexe de la salle des quatre colonnes
avec Stéphanie des pierres et Elsa
Mondin Gava alors avant de commencer et
bien le débat on va tout de suite vous
rejoindre Elsa pour essayer de
comprendre ce qui se passe puisque la
séance est suspendue jusqu'à 21h les
députés les sénateurs se sont réunis
pour très peu de temps finalement oui
exactement Brigitte si vous vouliez
encore du suspense et des
rebondissements et bien nous allons être
servi ce soir pourquoi vous l'avez dit
bien parce que cette commission mixte
paritaire elle a duré que quelques
minutes elle a commencé un petit peu
après 17h pour être quasiment
immédiatement suspendu suspension
pendant plus
d'unh50 et puis ensuite et bien elle a
recommencé pour être à nouveau suspendu
jusqu'à 21h cette fois les députés et
les sénateurs n'était pas tous présents
dans la salle de la commission mixte
paritaire puisque les représentants de
la droite tenaient eux un conciliabule
dans une salle à côté pendant ce
temps-là nous les journalistes nous
sommes toujours dans cette salle des
quatre colonnes vous le voyez toujours
nombreux les journalistes et des députés
des sénateurs des opposition de gauche
ou de rassemblement national sont venus
et bien nous alimenter sur ce qui se
passait pendant 30 toutes les 30 toutes
les 40 minutes même si eux sont un petit
peu en dehors des négociations
puisqu'ils nous disent que c'est bien
entre la majorité et les répu rblain que
ça coince voire même entre certains
républicains entre eux alors merci
elsamondangava pour toutes ces
informations et puis vous revenez vers
vous vers nous dès que vous avez
d'autres d'autres réactions je vous
présente à présent mon plateau et mes
invités pour cette émission spéciale
Véronique louvagi bonjour et merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes députés les
républicains de l'Orne Franck alizio
bonsoir député rassemblement national
des bouches du rô et Antoine léomand
bonsoir bienvenue à vous vous êtes
député la France insoumise de lesson et
notre grand témoin ce soir Arnaud
Benedetti bonsoir merci d'être là vous
êtes rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire alors
Véronique louvagi on apprend que les
républicains ont demandé une suspension
de séance de cette commission mixte
parétaire jusqu'à 21h et d'ailleurs
cette commission elle s'est très peu
réunie il y a eu beaucoup de conciliabul
du côté des républicain qu'est-ce qui se
passe écoutez je crois que c'est un
sujet compliqué dès le début nous avons
affirmé que finalement nous souhaitions
une politique migratoire de de fermeté
c'est-à-dire que l'État reprenne le
contrôle des flux migratoires ensuite
une fois que cette politique est est
déterminée il nous faut prévoir sa mise
en œuvre et et ensuite ses modalités
d'application que ce soit en terme de
moyens de contrôle et de sanction donc
en fait c'est très compliqué vous vous
le voyez et nous l'avons vu d'ailleurs
au Sénat lorsque le Sénat s'est saisi du
projet de loi du gouvernement il y a eu
énormément d'articles additionnels
énormément de suj qui ont été abordés
qu'il ne l'était pas forcément dans le
texte initial je pense par exemple à
l'aide médicale d'État donc voyez alors
on va renir sur les différents points de
ce texte d'accord de désaccord mais ce
qu'il y a c'est que on nous avait dit
qu'il y avait eu beaucoup de réunions
entre la majorité Elisabeth borne les
républicains et puis on avait
l'impression qu'il y avait pratiquement
un accord avant d'entrer en CMP et là on
ne sait plus finalement si vous allez
parvenir à vous mettre d'accord alors
écoutez-moi moi j'ai euh était plusieurs
fois membrre des commissions mixtes
paritaires je voudrais dire que sur un
grand nombre de textes les commissions
mixtes paritaire aboutissent à un accord
en dehors des textes budgétaires où
quasiment il n'y a jamais d'accord quand
il y a une commission mixte paritaire il
faut bien savoir que cela se prépare en
amont c'est ce qui se fait ici sur le
texte d'immigration mais c'est assez
classique en général cela se prépare
entre les rapporteur le rapporteur du
texte au Sénat le rapporteur du texte à
l'Assemblée nationale là il il s'avère
que dans ce cas précis le gouvernement
est un peu plus présent dans les
discussions que ce qui peut l'être euh
dans dans les textes ordinaires mais euh
moi j'ai vu des des CMP où quasiment
tout avait été bien organisé et durant
la CMP il apparaissait que quelques
points n'avaient pas été abordés et donc
qu'il y ait eu des suspensions de séance
demandé parce qu'à chaque fois que vous
avez un point dont vous vous rendez
compte qu'il n'a pas été abordé euh cela
nécessite une rédaction euh donc un
aspect technique un aspect juridique à
évoquer et puis là il y a probablement
des aspects politiques également ça veut
dire que vous restez quand même
optimiste oui je je reste optimiste je
pense que du côté des républicains nous
souhaitons que ça aboutisse mais en
revanche nous avons nos lignes rouges he
qui ont été clairement exprimé qui sont
connu connus des des des Français et des
uns et des autres et j'ai le sentiment
en tout cas que du côté du gouvernement
il y a une volonté que ça aboutisse du
côté de la majorité également donc moi
je reste optimiste mais il faut que tous
les points soient abordés et et nous
avons émis nos lignes rouges qui n'ont
pas changé hein je crois qu'éic ce ti
Olivier Marlec sont toujours été très
clair sur sur on va revenir bien sûr sur
ces lignes rouges au cours de ce débat
Franck alisio le rassemblement national
à l'immigration au cœur de son de son
projet depuis de de très nombreuses
années est-ce que vous vous souhaitez un
accord de cette CMP ou vous souhaitez
faire échouer le gouvernement
nous avons aussi si on peut dire no nos
lignes rouges la me c'était une bonne
chose que l'aide médicale d'État
disparaisse au profit d'une aide
médicale d'urgence euh et c'est en train
de de de disparaître à nouveau de enfin
la suppression de la me la me en train
d'être
rétabli il y a aussi la question
évidemment de l'article 4 bis
c'est-à-dire la
régularisation des des clandestins et ça
nous sommes opposés et ça c'est maintenu
alors ça dépend sous quelle forme
évidemment ça sera l'objet de la CMP
mais ça c'était maintenu y compris dans
dans le projet du du du Sénat euh 3ise
gros problème de ce de ce texte c'est
quelle est laelle est l'application de
la feuille de route de Bruxelles
c'est-à-dire la répartition des des
migrants sur l'ensemble du territoire et
compris sur les communes rurales cela
aussi pour nous c'est un problème
important euh pour il y avit justement
une réunion à Bruxelles aujourd'hui sur
si on excep ces trois ces trois sujets
et en particulier celui de la
régularisation puisqueévidemment c'est
là que va être le N et la manière de de
de l'appliquer parce que en gros si
c'est une demande au préfet que le
préfet dit oui ou non et partir moment
où le préfet dit non bah c'est c'est non
et que l'absence de réponse du préfet ne
vaut pas acceptation puisque c'est ça un
petit peu le débat technique ça change
les choses donc si on a s' n'y a plus
cette cette régularisation alors pour
faire simple cette loi ce sera à peu
près 10 % de ce qu'il faudra faire pour
résoudre le problème de l'immigration
alors parce qu'il manque les 90 %
faut-il voter contre cette loi c'est
c'est c'est c'est vous qui posez la
question mais répondez-y en même temps
mais pardon répondez-y en même temps
est-ce que ça vaut le coup si il y a
quand même 10 % de mesures tout dép tout
dépend les 10 % si par exemple on
contente l' l'ile gauche de de la
macronie en gardant la la l'article 4
bis de de manière souple de manière à ce
que bah si le préfet ne répond pas ben
hop il y a il y a régularisation dans
ces cas-là la question ne se pose pas on
en votera non évidemment vous savez
c'est surtout un psychodrame entre la
majorité LR madame Bor Monsieur bounau
le Maire Monsieur Darmanin enfin voilà
c'est quelque chose de très on va voir
si peut-être enfin si demain si si ce
sort le texte un texte trop trop trop
trop pas soupli par rapport à ce qui
était sorti du Sénat et vooté ça
voudrait dire que quelque part les LR
rejoignent la la la la majorité
présidentielle on on va en parler et et
d'ailleurs il y a un député Renaissance
Antoine Armand député renaissance de
haute savoix qui nous qui nous rejoint
en attendant installez-vous
tranquillement Antoine léomand vous vous
représentez la gauche sur ce plateau et
la France insoumise en particulier euh
est-ce que vous vous souhaitez vous
souhaitez un retrait du texte euh du
coup vous il faut que cette CMP s'arrête
c'était la la la demande notamment de de
Patrick canner de du du Parti socialiste
ce soir moi j'ai entendu ce qu'a dit le
président de la République il a dit que
s'il y avait pas d'accord le texte
serait retiré donc ça serait une bonne
nouvelle pour les Français que ce texte
soit retiré parce que il correspond à
aucun des besoins sur l'immigration
enfin je vous entends parler
d'immigration en réalité ce texte traite
absolument de rien de sérieux vous nous
dites il faut supprimer laame bon ben la
suppression de laame les Espagnols ont
essayé ils sontevenenus dessus parce
qu'ils ont constaté que ça coûtait plus
cher de supprimer l'aide médicale d'État
c'est-à-dire de soigner les gens au
moment où c'est pas encore trop grave de
les soigner plutôt que de faire cette
aide médicale d'urgence dont vous parlez
et donc de les soigner au moment où
c'est des urgences vitales je enfin à
moins que vous vouliez laisser les gens
mourir sur notre territoire ça ne fera
pas faire d'économie c'est-à-dire
dites-le à ce moment-là que c'est ça que
vous voulez faire laissez mourir les
gens sur le territoire parce sinon ça
règle rien la régularisation des
travailleurs sans papier je encore une
fois moi j'ai j'ai du mal à comprendre
pourquoi on s'oppose à une
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier compte tenu du fait fait que
quand on régularise les travailleurs
sans papiers ce que ça provoque c'est
une augmentation générale des salaires
ou plutôt je comprends bien pourquoi la
droite ne veut et l'extrême droite ne
veut pas régulariser les travailleurs
sans papier c'est que ça provoque une
pression à la baisse sur les salaires et
que le patronat est très content de
cette pression à la baisse sur les
salaires enfin vous nous avez dit que il
fallait sur la la question de la
répartition du territoire la répartition
des des personnes en situation de
migration sur le territoire en vous êtes
député des bouches du rô moi je suis
député de lesesson dans lesess sones il
y a des territoir ruraux et j'ai grandi
pour ma part moi j'ai grandi dans une
dans un département rural le principal
problème qu'on a c'est la dépopulation
dans les zones rurales
donc dire que l'immigration c'est une
catastrophe c'est complètement absurde
dans tout un tas de petit de petits
villages de France ce sont des personnes
qui sont des personnes d'origine
étrangère qui rouvrent des boulangeries
des petits commerces et qui font vivre
les territoires ruraux je ne vois pas
pourquoi on parle d'immigration
systématiquement en présentant les
aspects négatifs et puis par ailleurs
enfin j'en concluri là-dessus si vous
voulez réellement parler des questions
de migration il va falloir à un moment
donné parler du capitalisme des accords
de libre échange de l'impérialisme en
Afrique et des raisons pour lesquelles
les gens quittent leur pays si c'est ça
dont vous voulez parler moi je suis
d'accord pour qu'on parle de ça mais ce
texte là il parle absolument pas de ça
alors on va faire un petit détour par
les quatre colonnes la salle des quatre
colonne où se trouve Stéphanie des
pierres parce que Stéphanie ce que l'on
apprend c'est qu'il y a une réunion en
ce moment même à Matignon entre la
majorité et les républicains pour tenter
de trouver un accord sur le texte de la
CMP oui Brigitte on l'a dit vous le
voyez derrière Mo moi la salle des
quatre colonnes s vidée car la Réunion
est interrompue et la discussion se
passe désormais à Matignon entre les
républicains et le camp présidentiel le
principal point d'achopppement c'est sur
les allocations logement vous le savez
la droite voulait faire en sorte qu'un
étranger doiv attendre 5 ans avant de
toucher des allocations familial il y
avait eu une sorte d'accord prè
commission mixte paritaire entre le camp
présidentiel et les républicains mais
les républicains disent que dans ce ces
allocations il y avait les allocations
logement la majorité dit non il n'y
avait pas les allocations logement ça ne
faisait pas partie de l'accord et c'est
ça qui pose problème et qui a suscité un
quiiproco depuis depuis 17h depuis le
début de cette réunion alors après
chacun se renvoie la Basle les
républicains disent que ce sont le les
les troupes présidentielles qui ne
respectent pas l'accord les troupes
présidentielles et la gauche disent
elles que c'est un désaccord entre les
députés les républicains et les
sénateurs les républicains la réunion à
matigon en ce moment devrait per mettre
d'y voir un peu plus clair et on vous
l'a dit tout à l'heure la réunion de
commission mixte paritaire ici à
l'Assemblée devrait reprendre vers 21h
en théorie merci Stéphanie des piier
alors Antoine Armand on comprend que il
y a un désaccord finalement sur un point
précis du texte entre la majorité et les
républicains on pensait que vous entriez
dans cette commission mixte paritaire
avec avec déjà des des points d'accord
et que tout était réglé finalement c'est
pas le cas quelles sont les chances de
parvenir à un accord c'est la vie
démocratique c'est ce qui se passe
lorsque une commission mixte paritaire
se réunit que des sénateurs de
différents groupes politiques des
députés de différents groupes politiques
parfois même des députés et des
sénateurs d'un même groupe qui sont pas
d'accord surt se retrouvent vous vous
dites c'est la FAU des républicains il
sont mal compris entre eux pas du tout
simplement on sait qu'il y a des
sensibilités différentes dans chaque
groupe et dans chaque chambre il y a un
débat sur un certain nombre de points
vous pointez c'est tout à fait normal le
point qui est aujourd'hui en discussion
qui fait l'objet en ce moment même de
réunion à Matignon permettez-moi aussi
de pointer tous les autres sur lesquels
depuis plusieurs jours nous avons eu un
accord avec qui avec les forces
politiques qui veulent bien discuter et
qui veulent bien discuter des mesures
sur lesquelles 70 % des Français sont
d'accord en entrant sur votre plateau
j'écoutis d'abord le rassemblement
national et ensuite la France insoumise
et je me disais finalement il y a
vraiment que sur les plateaux de
télévision qui sont pas aux abonnés
absents sur un texte comme ça qui engage
le pays plus présent que vous à
l'assemblée que qu'on-il fait ils ont
refusé de débattre d'un texte non pas
voulu
qui s passé le rassemblement national
matin midi et soir nous explique que
l'alpha l'oméga de la politique du
gouvernement ça doit être l'immigration
nous avons un texte de lutte contre
l'immigration que font-ils ils ne
veulent même pas en débattre et il
votent avec celles et qui consid l'exact
contraire que l'immigration vous souitez
un accord en tout cas ce soir avec les
répu je souhaite que nous ayons un
accord sur les mesures qui font
consensus chez les Français qui sont
passés au filtre du Sénat de la
commission des lois et d'un accord entre
les forces politiques qui sont présentes
ça s'appelle la vie institutionnelle que
ceux qui ont refuser le débat se plaigne
aujourd'hui qu'il est lieu dans une
enceinte démocratique et
institutionnelle c'est quand même
vraiment le comble alors j'aimerais vous
entendre Arnaud Benedetti déjà sur ce
que vous avez entendu ici sur ce plateau
et puis est-ce que vous pensez que les
les parties prenant dire la majorité et
les républicains ont toutes les deux
intérêt à trouver un accord sur ce texte
vraisemblablement moi ce qui me frappe
si vous voulez dans ce débat et de dans
ce qu'on ce qu'on est en train de vivre
depuis maintenant le début enfin le
milieu de l'après-midi c'est que une
finé ça dit quelque chose sur l'enjeu
politique que que constitue la question
migratoire dans ce pays depuis all
presque 40 ans parce que finalement
l'enjeu migratoire est devenu un enjeu
politique majeur et saillant dans dans
notre vie politique au début des années
80 ou voire à la fin des années 70
plutôt début des années 80 et quand on
on regarde les prises de positions des
uns et des autres on voit bien que c'est
certainement l'un des enjeux les plus
clivants au sein même du champ politique
peut-être moins au niveau de l'opinion
publique parce que quand on regarde les
sondages d'opinion il y a finalement
aujourd'hui globalement une forme de
convergence sur finalement ce qui doit
être aux yeux d'une majorité de
l'opinion une politique migratoire qui
serait une politique migratoire
maîtrisée alors après on peut en parler
hein je veux dire des peut parler des
modalités d'application évidemment mais
je crois que c'est ce qui est frappant
c'est que la la scène parlementaire à
laquelle nous sommes en train d'assister
est révélatrice j'allais dire de la
force de cet enjeu parce que c'est un
enjeu qui est considéré comme
existentiel il est considéré par exist
comme existentiel par une grande partie
de l'opinion publi et il est il est
considéré comme existentiel par une
grande partie des forces politiques donc
il est évident que si vous voulez on est
en train de rentrer dans une espèce de
couloir parlementaire à travers cette
CMP qui ne peut être que difficile et on
voit bien que jusqu'au dernier mot on
disait par le passé on disait par le
passé une bonne commission mixte
paritaire c'est une commission qui est
négociée à 98 % en amont et on règle les
deux les deux derniers pour dans les
dans les derniers heectomètres là en
l'occurrence je sais pas si on est dans
les deux derniers pour mais en tout cas
on est dans ce cas de figure où on sent
bien que ben il faut qu'on se mette
d'accord mais qu'on y arrive pas
totalement et puis ensuite bon vous
l'avez très justement dit il y a des
sensibilités différentes au sein
notamment des principales parties
prenantes aujourd'hui qui cherchent un
accord tant du côté des LR que du côté
de la majorité moi j'ai compris que par
exemple la position du groupe LR à
l'Assemblée nationale n'était pas
toujours tout à fait la même que celle
du groupe LR au Sénat il pouvait y avoir
parfois des nuances qui s qui sétent
exprimé NOTAM
av alors ça semblerait s'accorder donc
tout cela n'est pas fondamentalement
surprenant après est-ce qu'il y aura un
accord ça nous allons voir on ne le sait
pas encore en tout cas vous l'avez dit
les Français qui sont interrogés dans
plusieurs enquêtes d'opinion souhaitent
à une large majorité des mesures forte
en matière d'immigration alors comment
ont-ils vécu l'adoption de la motion qui
a permis la semaine dernière de rejeter
le texte sans même l'examiner ce weekend
les députés Renaissance ELR sont
retournés en circonscription Dario
bergogot et Clément on suivi violette
spilbou et Anne lorblin à la rencontre
de leurs électeurs
regardez si loin si proche de
l'hémicycle Saur dans le menéloir c'est
la circonscription d'Anne l Blin député
les républi Bour elle a voté pour la
motion de rejet du projet de loi sur
l'immigration il y a une semaine sur le
terrain ses électeurs ont suivi ce
moment avec attention oui trè bien
regard ça
près j'ai été voir avit voté pas
voté ah donc j'tais suivi ah ouais ouais
là vous avez un sacré en jeu quand même
ah ou c'est
sûr ah mais c'est pas un sujet sur
lequel on peut se permettre de de
flancher bon vous allez bien et ben oui
très bien et vous ça se passe bien
l'assemblée bah écoutez vous avez un peu
suivi ce qui s'est passé cette semaine
la situation bah c'est ça c'est ça sur
le sujet de l'immigration c'est
aujourd'hui ou oui c'est important je
crois que il y a il y a le rassemblement
national derrière hein hein mais après
on fait pas de la politique on fait pas
de la politique par rapport au
rassemblement national par rapport à
laanupes moi je sais ce que j'ai comme
responsabilité je sais qu'elle doit être
mon rôle je sais ce qu'on me dit sur le
terrain faire tomber le texte à
l'Assemblée pour revenir à la version
plus dure du Sénat comme base de
négociation voilà le coup politique des
républicains que doit vendre an lorblin
pour partir d'une copie qui soit durcie
et plus ferale voilà cétait ça
notre et quand on voit tout ce qui se
passe tous les jours je crois qu' un
moment c'est bon laisser rentrer tout le
monde légaliser les gens qui sont
rentrés illégalement moi je considère
que c'est pas la stratégie semble plutôt
comprise et approuvé en particulier chez
les militants du parti présents aussi
sur le marché qui est à un moment donné
une prise de position du groupe et en il
y a eu une espèce de soulagement ah il
se passe quelque chose on va peut-être
enfin se laisser réentendre et ça c'est
vachement important je trouve pour la
base militante on est 62 mais on a un
rôle à jouer on l'a dit on est
suffisamment important pour faire
basculer une majorité dans un sens ou
dans un autre si les militants et les
élus les républicains semble
requinquer l'ambiance n'est pas la même
dans la majorité à Lille la députée du
Nord violette speedbou anime une réunion
Renaissance le moment est difficile la
motion de rejet du texte a laissé des
traces et tout un tout un travail gros
travail comme ça abattu et puis tu oui
oui ça fait quand même un an qu'on est
dessus quoi et puis il a quand même fait
des efforts la loi va revenir encore
plus dur ils vont reprendre le texte dé
qu'elle était pas vraiment validée oui
comment vous voyez les choses vous
là-dessus ah non je veux bien qu'elle
soit validée oui parce que parce que là
vraiment en fait il y a des étrangers
qui ont la haine pour la France dans ce
contexte compliqué la députée tente de
remobiliser les troupes on espère tous
effectivement que la CMP sera conclusive
et que nous pourrons voter à 16h15 mardi
donc soyez avec nous en ce moment parce
que ça va être d équilibrees difficile
j'espère que les partis d'opposition qui
se sont ligués pour faire un coup
politique au moment où ils ont souhaité
le faire et qui était plutôt réussi il
nous ont mis en situation de faiblesse
et bien aujourd'hui entendront raison
sur ce qui est bon pour les Français la
commission mixte paritaire qui s'ouvre
ce lundi sera suivie de près dans les
circonscriptions tout comme les votes
qui s'en suivront en cas d'accord
Antoine Armand on sent qu'il y a un peu
d'inquiétude chez vos électeurs et la
nécessité de trouver quand même une une
solution pour sortir de cette crise et
cette inquiétude elle existe chez tous
les Français je veux dire vendredi
j'étais dans ma circonscription à NC je
discutais avec des électeurs des
citoyens de gauche de droite mais je
vais vous dire il y a que nous qui
raisonnons en mesure de gauche et mesure
de droite moi je discute avec des
électeurs de gauche qui pens
ex comprends pas pourquoi expulser des
étrangers délinquant c'est un débat en
France un étranger délinquant qui
présente une menace pour l'ordre public
il n'a rien à faire sur notre quelles
que soient les conditions et à l'inverse
ilsous ont dit je comprends pas pourquoi
on fait tout un Pat à caisse de
régulariser des travailleurs qui sont
certes sans papier mais qui travaill
depuis des années sur le territoire
national qui cotise il pay des
cotisations sociales il contribu à
l'effort national on parle pas de
centaines de milliers de personnes on
parle de quelques milliers c'est pas une
mesure d'extrême gauche ou de droite et
au fond c'est ça que je trouve
intéressant c'est le travail et c'est le
travail qu'on doit mener en commission
mixte paritaire c'est d'arriver à une
aspiration populaire et à de
l'efficacité à de l'efficacité et pas à
des postures alors chez les républicains
on a vu aussi à lblin sur le sur le
terrain les LR vous disent bon bah c'est
bien on repart de la version du Sénat
mais en même temps faut transformer
l'essai c'est ce qu'on comprend oui mais
je crois que de toute façon vous avez un
peu la pression quand même pour trouver
un accord oui et évidemment parce qu'il
y a un enjeu déterminant entre une CMP
conclusive ou une CMP non conclusive la
situation sera complètement différente
mais du côté des républicains et ça
toujours été finalement notre ligne nous
avons intérêt à pousser nos propositions
nous avons intérêt à pousser nos
orientations et à faire en sorte qu'elle
soit le mieux entendue possible et cette
motion de Roger ce vote en faveur de la
motion de Roger c'était justement ça de
faire entendre la voix des républicains
au travers la version du Sénat et
d'organiser finalement une reprise du
texte des discussions sur la base du du
Sénat je crois que les les Français ils
sont assez pragmatiques sur le sujet de
de l'immigration en fait ils nous
demandent une maîtrise des flux
migratoires et de l'autre côté une fois
qu'on a déterminé cette maîtrise je
dirais une mise en œuvre des politiques
migratoires et tout ce qui concerne les
régularisations massives en tout cas je
crois que ça n'est pas admissible on ne
peut pas partir d' d'un d'un préalable
en se disant que un certain nombre de
personnes arrivent en situation
irrégulière sur le pays et ipso facto on
les régulariserait non je crois que les
régularisations doivent demeurer
exceptionnels et je crois savoir que sur
cet article 4 bis ce qui va en sortir en
tout cas c'est que ça reste à la fois
exceptionnel et que cela ne constitue
pas un droit opposable en tout cas ce
sont des lignes rouges que nous avons
euh évoqué quant à laame la me nous
savions tous et cela est est dit que euh
si la me enfin ou la transformation ou
la suppression de laame et la création
d' Amu resté dans dans le T cétait un
cavalier
C euh donc euh nous avons un engagement
de la première ministre qu'un texte
viendra je dirais début 2024 la première
ministre a écrit à Gérard Larché
effectivement promettre que il y aurait
une réforme de de l'aide médicale d'État
en J et moi je je je je je je m'en
satisfit parce que quand nous regardons
le rapport qui a été commandé par la
première ministre stéphanini evvin il
dit beaucoup de choses très
intéressantes il dit que nous sommes un
des pays les plus généreux parmi h pays
et il exclut évidemment l'Espagne mais
parmi les SEP autres pays qui étaient
évoqués dans dans le rapport de l'IGF et
Ligas en 2019 nous sommes le pays le
plus généux il dit aussi qu' y a pas de
dérapage sur l'aide médicale d'État ce
rapport non il ne dit pas vraiment ça il
dit que l'aide médicale d'État n'est pas
le seul facteur
d'attractivité pour faire venir des des
personnes en France mais il dit que
l'aide médicale d'État participe au
maintien des personnes en situation
irrégulière sur notre pays voilà et il
parle également d'un certain nombre de
personnes qui à partir de titre de
séjour viendrai comme un canal d'entrée
je prends reprends le mot exactement de
ce rapport stéphanini Evin pour les
systèmes de soins donc vous voyez il y a
des vrais sujets et je crois que la
première ministre a raison de dire qu'il
faut réformer en tout cas moi je m'en
réjouis nous avions les républicains
proposé une résolution au printemps
dernier justement pour pour proposer une
réforme de l'aide
médical revoir le panier de soins parce
que c'est de ça dont il s'ag alors avant
de poursuivre ce débat un petit détour
par la salle des quatre colonnes où se
trouve Elsa mondingava Elsa il y a bien
une réunion en ce moment même à Matignon
oui c'est assez incongru on a suspendu
cette commission mixte paritaire et on
sait que les responsables du texte de la
majorité sont en ce moment à Matignon
évidemment on le savait les négociations
elles ont eu lieu autour de la première
ministre on les a vu mercredi jeudi se
sont poursuivis ce weekend et donc la
majorité est en train de faire un point
autour de la première ministre selon des
sources parlementaires les républicains
pourrai également se rendre à Matignon
je garde un conditionnel puisque ce qui
est vrai un moment peut s'avérer faut
quelques minutes plus tard on essaiera
d'obtenir confirmation de l'information
ce qu'on sait c'est que pour l'instant
c'est la seule majorité qui est présente
on voit pour essayer bien de dénouer de
trouver peut-être un accord de
comprendre comment certains ont pu
comprendre une chose lors de la
négociation d'autres une autre chose
puisque ce qu'on dit ici aux quatre
colonnes brigitte c'est que soit
quelqu'un ment soit il y a eu une erreur
ou un problème de communication mais
d'un camp comme de l'autre c'est la
confiance dans les négociations qui a
été entamé autour de cette question des
aPL voilà merci Elsa mondangava pour ces
ces précisions c'est donc la majorité
qui est bien réunie à matigon à la
demande de de la première ministre pour
tenter de trouver un accord sur ce ce
point de blocage autour des des aides au
logement Antoine léomand vos électeurs
on y revient vous est-ce qu'ils ont
considéré que c'était une victoire
puisque vous avez participé au rejet du
texte est-ce qu'ils ont considéré que
cétait une victoire sachant que
finalement vous allez peut-être au bout
du compte être l'arroseur arrosé étant
donné qu'on repart d'une version du
Sénat qui est beaucoup plus dure et que
s'il y a un compromis le projet de loi
immigration sera beaucoup plus dur que
la version initiale déjà premièrement
dommage que vous soyez pas venu vu que
vous faisiez accompagné des députés il y
avait un rassemblement des chauffeurs
VTC il y a quelques jours et je suis
allé les soutenir et quand je suis
arrivé avec mon camarade Thomas porte
nous avons été accueillis comme ceux qui
ont fait tomber Gérald daranin donc vous
voyez que il y a ce qui est dit sur un
certain nombre de plateau télé par nos
adversaires politiques qui évidemment
essayent de transformer une victoire de
la gauche en défaite enfin je veux dire
cette victoire de que nous avons obtenu
c'est le fait que pendant de semaines on
s'est vite effectivement vous l'avez dit
un débat qui est un débat raciste parce
que on l'a eu en commission vous AZ
gagné une bataille mais est-ce que vous
n'alz pas perdre la guerre non parce que
il se serait passé exactement la même
chose si le texte avait été adopté à
l'Assemblée nationale il y aurait eu une
commission mixte paritaire et à la fin
c'était de nouveau les républicains qui
avaient la main sur cette commission mix
du Sénat qui était la base de
négociation ça aurait été ça aurait été
exactement la même chose à la fin
puisque c'est les républicains qui ont
la main sur cette histoire non je je
veux il y a plusieurs choses qu'on été
dites et sur lesquelles je voudrais
revenir vous dites nous sommes le pays
le plus généreux comme si pas moi qui le
dit c'est st très bien mais vous dites
nous sommes le pays le plus généreux et
c'est dramatique je je trouve ça positif
nous sommes le pays le plus généreux
drtique et bien je vous dis moi qu'on
pourrait s'en féliciter et se dire tiens
c'est vrai nous sommes le pays le plus
généreux c'est une bonne nouvelle
combien ça coûte exactement cette aide
médical d'État ça coûte 0,6 % du budget
de la sance exactement 1,2 milliard
d'euros merci de le dire parce que c'est
trois fois moins que la suppression
deisf vous voyez si jamais il faut
récupérer de l'argent on pourrait
peut-être aller le chercher chez les
riches qu'on a gavé enfin qu'on a gavé
pas moi que Monsieur Macron et ses
députés on gavé vous voyez comment on
utilise un chiffre en disant oh là là ça
coûte une fortune c'est dramatique les
Français qui travaillent pour les pour
les étrangers et cetera d'accord mais
les Français en attendant ils
travaillent ils font aussi gagner
beaucoup d'argent au milliardaires et
cela alors par contre aucun problème
pour leur donner tout l'argent du monde
ensuite je voudrais juste vous dire
quelque chose vous dites un étranger
délinquant qui représente une menace
pour le pays il n'a pas sa place en
France c'est déjà dans la loi c'est déjà
dans la loi que quand quand il y a un
trouble à l'ordre public ou une menace
de trouble à l'ordre public on peut
expulser quelqu'un ensuite sa que là on
introduit la double P aussi dans le pro
j'ess de répondre l'ensemble des
arguments ét
nous refusons de débattre bon en
l'occurrence je suis député de la
commission des lois j'étais dans la
commission des lois tout le long des
débats ça a duré 43 he donc je sais pas
si on peut dire qu'on a refusé de
débattre par contre j'ai vu samedi
dernier samedi dernier j'ai vu madame
borne une minute faire un 493 et
repartir donc en matière de quelqu'un
qui essaie d'éviter les débats je trouve
que la première ministre se pose là et
enfin sur les questions d'immigration
vous avez dit tout à l'heure c'est un
sujet depuis 1980 moi je considère que
c'est un sujet que certains montent en
épingle depuis 1980 mais en réalité ça a
toujours été un sujet pour la France les
questions d'immigration je suis l'enfant
d'immigrés Belg et italien je ne suis
pas sûr qu'il soit entré euh de manière
autorisée sur le territoire national que
fuyait-il la misère ah bah tiens comme
d'autres aujourd'hui quelle est la
différence et bien nous n'avons pas la
même couleur de peau et moi ça ne se
voit pas que je suis un immigré italien
et belge d'accord mais il y a un certain
nombre de problèmes il y a un certain
nombre de personnes qui ont un certain
nombre de problèmes avec les gens qui
n'ont pas ma couleur de peau je veux
dire un dernier truc sur ça moi j'ai
plein de compatriotes qui n'ont pas ma
couleur de peau qui viennent me voir en
ce moment en disant l'ambiance est
tellement nauséabonde que j'ai envie de
quitter mon pays mais ils aiment la
France je sais plus qui disait ça tout à
l'heure quelqu'un dans les les gens vous
interroger c'est des gens qui aiment la
France qui n'ont pas envie de la en
projet de loi pour durcir l'immigration
illégale c'est ça que je suis en train
de vous dire c'est que l'ambiance
globale qui est mise dans ce pays avec
certaines personnes comme Madame Marion
maréchal qui parle de français de papier
toute cette ambiance là fait qu'un
certain nombre de nos compatriotes qui
sont aussi intégrés que ce que l'on
pourrait souhaiter qui qui aime
notre pays qui porte fièrement le
drapeau tricolore et qui chante
fièrement la Marseillaise en ont
pardessus la tête qu'il soit ramené sans
cesse à leurs origines francise je
voudrais vous entendre parce que vous
vous avez aussi vous avez aussi voté
pour cette motion de rejet donc pour
refuser un débat sur l'immigration alors
que vous auriez pu avoir une tribune
pour porter vos idées sur l'immigration
est-ce que vos électeurs ont bien
compris pourquoi vous aviez voté ce ce
rejet du texte ah totalement quand on
leur explique qu'il fallait qu'il
manquait 10 jours à Gérald armanin pour
acheter un par un les députés LR pour
faire voter au final ce projet là je je
prire qu'il comprennent et nos électeurs
ils veulent un vrai débat c'estàd un un
débat référendaire un référendum sur la
question de l'immigration mais ce débat
dit pas mal de choses sur le clivage
politique en France et c'est c'est
intéressant parce que là les choses sont
claires vous avez d'un côté l'extrême
gauche qui considère que l'immigration
est une bénédiction c'est les fameuses
chances pour la France vous avez
Renaissance mais au moins c'est clair au
moins c'est net vous avez Renaissance
que c'est un petit peu un mal nécessaire
immigration voilà pour Renaissance c'est
un mal nécessaire donc il faut faire
avec euh et vous avez les républicains
qui qui savent très bien que pour pour
pas encore diviser par deux leur groupe
au prochaines élections législatives bah
il faut parler com comme Marine Le Pen
mais ils finiront par agir comme
Emmanuel comme Emmanuel Macron donc nous
pourquoi on considère que c'est un
problème l'immigration c'est un problème
au quotidien et c'est un problème exist
c'est un problème au quotidien pour les
Français et existentiel pour la France
et bien tout simplement parce que par
exemple chez moi dans les Bouches du rô
dans une ville en particulier Marseille
euh 55 % de la des délinquants
interpellés sont étrangers ce ne sont
pas les chiffres de Marine Le Pen ni ce
de Jordane bardellaa sont les chiffres
de Gérald armanin ministre d'intérieur
qui mieux placé euh pourquoi parce que
aujourd'hui en France on consacre 44
millions de de de d'euros euh de moyens
pour euh faciliter euh comment dire
organiser euh les octf les obligations
de quitter le territoire et on donne
dans le même temps 900 millions aux ass
iation amis de monsieur léom qui eux
font tout leur boulot deociationation
proimmigration qui font en qui font en
sorte
d'empêcher d'empêcher d'empêcher
expulsion d'empêcher expulsion légal
dans l'illégalité mais ENF ils sont en
France vous
lesempchez laisse-moir et enfin on a
500000 émigrés chaque année qui rentre
légalement sur le territoire on ne peut
plus les accueillir on ne peut plus les
intégrer économiquement par le travail
on ne peut plus les assimiler
culturellement voilà tout simplement
voilà pourquoi nous somm contre
l'immigration nous sommes pour un M
est-ce que
finalement est-ce que finalement on
parle souvent de leupénisation des
esprits est-ce que finalement l'idée que
l'immigration est un problème dans le
pays à à gagné les têtes des Français
aujourd'hui très clairement vous savez
pour répondre à Monsieur Léomont moi je
constate une chose c'est il faut pegy
disait il faut voir ce que l'on voit et
dire ce que l'on voit clairement euh
dans les années 70 il n'y avait pas un
enjeu qui était lié à la question
migratoire c'était un sujet globalement
qui était traité à très bas bruit ce qui
s'est passé c'est qu'en effet à partir
des années 80 on a vu une politisation
de cet enjeu ça c'est une réalité on
peut le regretter on peut s'en féliciter
pour certains mais c'est une réalité
avec laquelle je pense tous les
politiques doivent faire et d'ailleurs
même un certain nombre de politiques de
gauche je me souviens que de Michel
Rocard en 88 ou 89 ici à l'Assemblée
nationale considérer que en effet le
sujet migratoire était devenu un sujet
qui interpellit le premier ministre de
gauche qu'il était donc on peut toujours
dire non le sujet n'existe pas la
réalité c'est que l'opinion publique la
vérité c'est que l'opinion publique et
les électeurs vous renvoient le sujet
donc vous ne pouvez pas ne pas le
traiter c'est une réalité après
évidemment il y a des modalités encore
une fois d'application qui sont
extrêmement différentes mais je voudrais
revenir quand même encore une fois moi
ce qui me frappe si vous voulez dans ces
débats depuis quelques jours c'est deux
choses c'est qu'en effet on voit un
champ politique qui est extrêmement
clivé sur cette question ça c'est une
réalité on le voit les débats auxquels
nous assistons le démontrre les
difficultés que la commission mixte
paritaire à être conclusive le démontre
vous diriez même un débat gauche- droite
qui se qui se qui réexiste trouve je
trouve qu'en effet sur ce sujetl on a le
sentiment que finalement les marqueurs
de gauche et de droite réapparaissent y
compris peut-être même au sein de la
majorité on verra d'ailleurs la
répercussion éventuelle d'une commission
mixte paritaire conclusive sur la
majorité je n'en sais strictement rien
mais on peut se poser on peut se poser
la question légitimement je crois qu'en
effet c'est un sujet qui fait partie de
l'histoire politique et où on a des
différences d'approche entre la droite
et la gauche mais pour répondre à votre
question clairement ce à quoi on assiste
depuis maintenant plus d'une vingtaine
d'années c'est que on a une droitisation
de l'opinion publique sur cette question
moi je me souviens dans les années 80
j'entendais des discours y compris à
droite de gens qui nous disait monsieur
Stasi qui a été parlementaire ici
pendant des années et des années qui a
été ministre qui était centriste avait
même écrit je crois un livre euh
intitulé l'immigration une chance pour
la
France on peut considérer aujourd'hui
que finalement ce ce ce ce late motif
mis à part à gauche et Monsieur Léomont
le représente en l'occurrence a plutôt
dis dis paru du débat public
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui la façon
dont la question de l'immigration est
abordée par une grande partie de
l'opinion publique et puis quand même
par une grande partie de la classe
politique c'est que c'est un sujet que
c'est un problème donc si vous voulez la
dimension positive de la de de la de de
la question migratoire c'est quand même
plus ou moins effilanché à la fois dans
les esprits mais aussi dans les
positionnements politiques Antoine
Armand justement s'il y a un accord en
CMP en commission mixte paritaire avec
les républicains est-ce que c'est pas la
fin du a en même temps c'est ce qu'on a
beaucoup entendu dans dans les
oppositions et est-ce que finalement il
y a pas une
droitisation du du camp macroniste à la
faveur de cet accord non d'abord je vous
l'ai dit tout à l'heure les concitoyens
sur le terrain ils ne raisonnent pas
comme ça ils promeuvent certaines
mesures ils sont contre d'autres mesures
et je pense que l'accord qu'on doit
trouver il est nécessaire pour plusieurs
raisons mais une qu'on a vu à l'instant
c'est qu'on a un double piège de nature
très différente qui nous est posé on a
d'un côté le rassemblement national qui
discute migration et puis qui à un
moment vous savez le le chasser le
naturel et puis revient au Galot
directement au château de Montretout il
s'agit de supprimer les les les aides
pour les restos du cœur pour le Secours
populaire vous allez j'imagine avoir un
QR code pour décider qui a le ventre
vide quand il est immigré clandestin et
quand il n'est pas immigré clandestin
dans la rue c'est ce que c'est ce que
vous venez de dire je pense que je vous
laisse la responsabilité de vos propos
je sais même pas si vous mesurez leur
gravité et l'autre piège que je regrette
au fond de la part de la France
insoumise et parce que et pourquoi vous
en fait ce que je ne comprends pas et je
le dis avec beaucoup de sincérité vous
ne voulez pas discuter du sujet
migratoire ce que je veux dire c'est que
on vous parle d'aide médical d'État
c'est pas un tabou pourquoi est-ce que
vous parlez de l'ISF on vous parle de la
régularisation des sans papiers on
pourrait en parler et vous refusez même
même le débat ici sur ce plateau ce que
je ne comprends pas pourquoi vous n'êtes
pas capable de reconnaître qu'il y a une
aspiration populaire à une meilleure
maîtrise de nos flux migratoires c'est
quand même quasiment consensel dans la
soci moi je reconnais qu'il y a une
aspiration populaire à ce que vous
appelez une meilleure maîtrise de nos
flux migratoires ce que je vous dis
c'est que le texte tel que vous tel
qu'il est fait là ne ne ne gère
absolument pas les flux migratoires
parce que si vous voulez gérer les flux
migratoires il faut se poser la question
des causes du départ caus non les
caus et non c'est pas que ça et
d'ailleurs dans l'aide au développement
on en a discuté également et dans l'a
dans l'aide au développement il y en
avait un certain nombre qui voulit
supprimer des aides au développement
bref mais si on veut parler des causes
du départ il faut aller regarder les
questions de guerre des guerres que
parfois nous provocquons nous-mêm par
exemple ce qui s'est passé en Libye ça
fait partie des choses qui se sont
passées petit 1 petit 2 le climat ça va
être la grande question de l'avenir et
si on ne traite pas les questions de
l'accueil d'un accueil correct on va
être effectivement avec beaucoup de gens
qui vont se déplacer et qui vont finir
par arriver sur notre territoire et vous
pourrez mettre les barbelet que vous
voulez vous pourrez mettre les murs que
vous voulez les gens passeront quand
même enfin je veux dire les gens ils
arrivaient à traverser la frontière
quand il y avait la Seconde Guerre
mondiale vous inquiétez pas que les gens
ils arrive à traverser des frontières
donc si vous voulez régler la question
correctement c'est ça qu'il faut poser
et enfin il y a une question majeure
mais qui nai jamais posé malheureusement
que j'ai posé en commission des lois
justement parce que j'ai participé au
débat et que Monsieur sooti parlait de
l'immigration de la Côte d'Ivoire ben
moi j'ai répondu la Côte d'Ivoire
parlons-en on a 375 millions de de de de
de commerce extérieur avec la la Côte
d'Ivoire qui est bénéficiaire dans notre
sens on envoie en Côte d'Ivoire des
médicaments et des produits manufacturés
et on récupère quoi du cacao voilà donc
si vous voulez faire en sorte que les
gens restent en Côte d'Ivoire parce que
vous n'aimez pas les Ivoiriens moi c'est
n'est pas mon problème moi j'ai pas de
problème avec les Ivoiriens j'ai de
problème AC personne moi je vois des
gens qui arrivent dans notre pays qui
arrivent dans notre pays d'ailleurs on
va le voir il y avait une manifestation
aujourd'hui à République de travailleurs
sans papier qui se sont réunis
effectivement pour défiler et demander
la nationalité mais justement c'est les
gens qui arrivent dans notre pays moi
j'aimerais parfois que vous par exemple
vous alliez discuter avec eux pour
parler avec eux pour connaître leur
histoire parce que c'est des gens qui
font quoi qui quittent leur pays
pourquoi parce que ils vont mal dans
leur famille ils ont envie d'aider leur
famille ça vous parle normalement la
famille à la droite ils ont envie
d'aider leur famille ils partent ils
viennent ils traversent parfois 15 20 30
pays parfois ils se font agresser
sexuellement parfois ils se font ils se
font frapper ils se font ils ont une vie
qui est difficile ils arrivent dans
notre pays ils ont l'impression d'enfin
arriver au pays des droits de l'homme et
du citoyen et qu'est-ce qui se passe ils
dorment dans des tentes sous le métro à
Paris c'est ça qui se passe et on nous
présente ça en disant oh les gens qui
viennent profiter des aides sociales en
France enfin c'est c'est en dehors de
toute
réalité je je veux juste direum hum non
précisément je ne suis pas celui qui
instrumentalise la misère humaine ceux
qui le fond sont ceux qui disent qu'il
faut durcir les conditions de l'accueil
pour éviter que les gens partent et
ce vous justement vous souhaitez durcir
ces conditions et notamment sur les
allocations familiales c'est un des
points qui fait débat en ce moment
c'estàdire que vous ne souhaitez pas
qu'il y ait desallocations quand un
étranger ne travaille pas sur le sol
français depuis au moins 5 ans voilà je
je crois je voudrais juste répondre à
Monsieur Lom monsieur le vous nous dites
que au motif qu'il y a des guerres ou
des impacts climatiques dans certains
pays il faudrait accueillir hier toutes
C personnes sans contrôle matrise non je
crois non nous pouvons il nous faut
avoir une maîtrise de nos flux
migratoires et c'est ce qu'attendent les
Français et pouvoir répondre oui quand
nous le voulons mais également non quand
nous ne le voulons il aurait pas fallu
accueillir les ukrainiien selon vous non
non mais attendez je crois que vous ne
pouvez pas raisonner de manière globale
en disant voilà il y a des guerres dans
un pays il y a des impacts climatiques
il faons un cas très concr r restera un
pays un pays d'asile vonque Lou on t
avir la maîtrise voilà et le choix de
euh de de la politique et également un
choix sur les régularisation à
intervenir nous ne pouvons pas
régulariser de manière massive tout le
monde Je je je viens viens à votre à
votre question sur les prestations
sociales effectivement c'est une
question c'est un point d'ailleurs qui
choque un certain nombre de de français
euh que des personnes qui arrivent en
France sans que pour autant ces
personnes et et participé euh je dirais
à la vie du pays et le droit aux
prestations dès leur arrivée enfin au
bout de 6 mois je crois qu'effectivement
derrière il y a derrière des droits il
doit y avoir des devoirs et je crois que
ça c'est très important donc j'ai je je
par exemple les aid pour le logement
vous vous trouvez qu'il faut les donner
quoi qu'il arrive ou est-ce qu'il faut
les réserver au bout d'un certain nombre
d'années sur le territoire je pense
qu'il faut les réserver au bout d'un
certain nombre d'années il faut mettre
des conditions il peut les aid log oui
même les aides au logement je crois c
que vous avez quand même un grand nombre
de Français aujourd'hui qui ont des
difficultés à se loger c'est c'est c'est
une question qui revient régulièrement
comment peut-on expliquer aux Français
que des personnes qui arrivent qui qui
auraient droit immédiatement dès leur
arrivé à une prestation sociale à une
allocation logement alors que un grand
nombre de personnes a des difficultés à
se loger voilà je crois qu'il faut que
nous fassions un choix sur la manière
dont nous voulons accueillir
effectivement des des étrangers je vrais
juste ajouter sur sur la CMP dire que au
Sénat les députés de enfin les sénateurs
plus exactement de de la majorité
présidentielle ont voté le texte du
Sénat voilà donc c'est dire que la CMP a
quand même en partant d'un texte du
Sénat euh à de fortes je dirais chance
d'aboutir parce il y avait un accord
entre la majorité et la droite voilà les
sénateurs de la majorité présidentielle
ont voté
le monava on vous retrouve vous êtes
salle des des quatre colonnes vous avez
entendu Véronique louvagi pour elle
effectivement les aides au logement ne
doivent pas être donné immédiatement
entre un immigré qui arriverait sur le
sol français tout à fait Brigitte et on
se rend bien compte que c'est cette
question des aPL qui devient le point
dur du texte le point qui cristallise
les tensions de cette commission mixte
paritaire on le sait les républicains
promettent de camper sur leur position
on sait aussi que cette question des aPL
elle a été qualifiée de ligne rouge pour
la la majorité pourtant c'est simple
Brigitte il faut bien que soit la droite
soit la majorité recule mais on le sait
chaque pas coûte cher aux uns et aux
autres alors soit la CMP elle peut
reprendre à 21h et on arrive à trouver
un compromis soit les deux camps peuvent
acter qu'ils n'arriveront pas à
s'entendre et dans ce cas la CMP la
commission mixte paritaire n'est pas
conclusive et on le sait c'est synonyme
d'abandon pur et simple du texte et ce
qui a promis le président de la
République et puis il y a une troisième
option puisqu'il faut penser à tous tous
les scénarios sont possibles pourquoi
pas se donner encore un peu de temps
normalement quand on convoque une
commission mixte paritaire c'est bien
pour aboutir un résultat est-ce que là
on pourrait laisser passer la nuit la
reporter un petit peu visiblement cette
solution peut-être envisagée même si de
mémoire c'est quand même très très très
rare qu'on en arrive à ce point oui de
mémoire ça n'arrive même jamais Amond
GABA merci pour toutes ces ces
informations Franck alziio il y a ce
point qui fait débat ce point de blocage
sur les aides au logement
on entendait Antoine léomand dire ça va
faire des SDF est-ce que on peut ne pas
donner d'aide au logement un immigré qui
arriverait sur le sol français enfin
c'est ce qu'on appelle les multiples
incitations et les multiples appels
d'air à à immigration en France c'est
évidemment du bon sens que de dire que
pendant un certain nombre d'années
Marine Le Pen pendant la présidentielle
proposait 5 ans c'est ce qui é à
l'origine dans le projet du Sénat
d'ailleurs voilà les 5 premières années
où on est en France on ne touche pas des
d'aide sociales y compris les
allocations de logement juste pour
revenir sur quelques points premièrement
monsieur Loman est très pessimiste ça ça
dit beaucoup de si vous étiez au pouvoir
d'ailleurs c'est il y a un côté bah
c'est l'anarchie on laisserait on
laisserait faire non les frontières ça
vous savez à l'époque on avait les
frontières dans ce pays il y a une
trentaine d'années on avait une de
vraies politique d'immigration avec de
de véritables règles B on avait pas
500000 personnes qui arrivaient chaque
année il y en av il y en avait 100000
voilà bah c'est ça la différence entre
des frontières pas fronties laissez-moi
finir vous demandez d'aller voir les
familles les les familles de ça
les par les
terroristestinrist qui
sontmigration nom il étaient pas
étrangers il étai
français la militante la militante
Renaissance elle même disait tout à
l'heure à la député oui mais il y a des
Y a certains étrangers qui viennent chez
nous et qui et qui sont ici qui
détestent la France bon c'est
Renaissance voy c'est pas nous ENF
dernier point les restos du cœur je suis
désolé de vous le dire monsieur le
député de R
mais votre politique sociale amène aussi
beaucoup encore des Français au reste du
cœur il n'y a pas que des clandestins au
reste du cœur par rapport à votouz voilà
Arnaud Benedetti je vis vous entendre
sur sur ce point de blocage est-ce que
ça vous
paraît si important que la CMP pourrait
échouer ah ben attendez votre question
c'est de savoir est-ce que ce point de
blocage est suffisamment important pour
que la CMP pour faire échouer l'ensemble
de la CMP en tout cas on a l'impression
que les uns et les autres négocient un
peu le dos au mur aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire qu'en effet les
républicains ont depuis maintenant la
l'adoption de la de la motion de rejet
considérer que s'il rentrait en
commission mixte paritaire comme le
souhaite le président de la République
c'était pour négocier à travers le texte
qui avait été voté au Sénat le seul
texte et et la totalité de ce texte pour
reprendre les mots je crois à peu près
de Monsieur sooti et en effet cette
questionl me semble-t-il était parti
prenante et ple pleinement intégrée dans
le dans le texte de loi tel qu'il avait
été voté au au au au Sénat donc ensuite
du côté du gouvernement enfin du côté de
la majorité je pense qu'on pense quand
même aussi aux conséquences h h aux
conséquences d'une de l'adoption d'une
motion enfin d'une motion de
l'adoption d'une commission mixte par
exemple paritaire conclusive et de voir
les répercussions que ça pourrait avoir
au sein de la majorité parce que on sait
très bien qu'il y a des lignes rouges
aussi qui ont été
affiché après la vraie question est de
savoir é si on a éche c'est l'implosion
de la
majorité que si on a échec c'est plus
qu'un incident c'est un événement
important dans cette législature on est
un point de bascule là du du quinena
Macron oui si vous voulez l'adoption de
cette motion de rejet a démontré
j'allais dire inviv ce que l'on sait
depuis le printemps 2022 c'est-à-dire
qu'en fait il n'existe pas une majorité
suffisamment stable pour que monsieur
Macron soit disons tranquille et
gouverne tranquillement durant tout ce
mondat vous savez la 5e République elle
a été établie de manière avec un
objectif simple c'est de dégager des
majorités dégager des majorités stables
c'est un régime qui est c'est un régime
qui avait été pensé par le général de
Goul qui était totalement traumatisé par
les régimes d'assemblée de la 3e et de
la 4e pour fabriquer de la stabilité et
permettre à un gouvernement de gouverner
quand vous n'avez plus de majorité ou
quand vous avez une majorité très
relative parce que le problème de Madame
borne historiquement sur la 5e
République c'est la première ministre
qui dispose de la majorité relative la
plus relative queun Premier ministre a
eu à sa disposition sous la 5e
République de Gaul l'avait eu enfin
Pompidou l'avait eu en 67 mais en 67 il
avait quand même des stabilisateurs à
droite qui lui per et puis 68 il a eu
une majorité absolue en 88 rocar avait
une majorité qui était moins relative
que celle de Madame elle était beaucoup
moins relative il avait le groupe UDC
union du centre sur sa droite et il
pouvait se débrouiller avec les
communistes pour caboter et est perduré
plus même s'il a fait 28
493 voulez oui oui et puis avec un droit
de tirage attendez un droit de tirage
illimité sur le 493 sur l'ensemble de la
session ordinaire ex donc c'est vrai que
c'est quand même un vrai problème si on
n arrive pas à un accord ce soir sur C
alors Antoine Armand on nous dit que la
commission mixte paritaire pourrait
s'interrompre et éventuellement
reprendre plus tard ce qui ce qui arrive
quand même très très rarement voire
quasiment jamais
euh est-ce que ce sont les informations
que vous avez est-ce que est-ce que ça
veut dire que finalement le le désaccord
est plus important qu'on le croit et la
la Réunion est en cours il faut voir
combien de temps les discussions durent
est-ce qu'il vaut mieux avoir une
discussion à 1230 ou à 8h du matin
honnêtement je pense pas que ce soit le
le le fond du sujet mais vous avez
raison vous rappeler vous rappelier les
évolutions de majorité on a beaucoup
débattu de la 5e République on le fait
encore on débat beaucoup des majorités
des majorités relative pardon mais comme
député de la majorité c'est pas un scoop
j'ai pas découvert lundi dernier qu'on
était en majorité relative moi ce que je
trouve intéressant c'est que
effectivement ce moment rappelle autre
chose rappelle quelque chose qui est
apparu très clairement en juin 2022
c'est le message qui nous a été envoyé à
cette assemblée au fond moi je
l'interprète de cette manière-là et les
les concitoyens ass autour me disent la
même chose ce qui nous ont dit c'est
travailler ensemble travailler ensemble
trouver des majorités avec telle ou
telle force politique à à à des mesures
efficaces qui qui t' droitisé votre
votre ligne quand vote la loi sur les
énergies renouvelables qui est
indispensable pour approfondir la
sécurité énergétique du pays dans les
prochaines années le temps de rouvrir
des centrales nucléire le temps de
d'assurer la transition écologique on le
fait avec une partie de la gauche avec
l'abstention d'une partie de la gauche
c'est une mesure efficace quand on vote
une loi sur la relance nucléaire on le
fait avec la droite qui est convaincue
et au fond quand vous en discutez avec
nos compatriotes il vous disent voilà
c'est ça qu'on attend donc on peut
relativiser élaborer élucubrer sur sur
une majorité relative de fait c'est ça
qui existe c'est une aspiration
nationale qui se retrouve aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée et donc c'est ça notre
devoir ensuite sur le texte sur le texte
et sur les allocation nous nous voulons
un accord nous voulons un accord parce
que est-ce que vous êtes prêts à céder
sur ce point des des aides au logement
nous ne sommes pas prêts à céder à tout
prix surtout quels sont les critères je
vous en donne un qui me paraît quand
même important quand on parle d'action
publique c'est l'efficacité il y a
aujourd'hui un délai de carence de 6
mois pour les prestations non
contributives celles qui sont pas liées
aux cotisations sociales quand vous vous
arrivez sur le sol français pendant 6
mois vous ne touchez pas ces prestations
ça s'appelle le délai de carence la
question c'est faut-il l'augmenter de
combien et à partir de quand l'augmenter
devient quelque chose qui fait une
différence fondamentale entre des
résidents français et quand est-ce qu'on
nrepasse une forme de promesse d'égalité
républicaine d'où les discussions que
nous avons sur le délai et d'où le fait
que oui il y a une ligne rouge dire que
aDVITAM etnam quelqu'un qui viendrait
sur le sol français ne pourrait pas
disposer des mêmes prestations qu'un
Français ou que quelqu'
20un français ça n'aurait pas de sens
donc c'est normal qu'il a une discussion
elle est difficile elle est ardue on a
nos convictions c'est à ça que servent
les réunions Véronique louvagi si la CMP
ne reprenait pas ce soir est-ce qu'on
considérerait que elle serait non
conclusive ou vous aveit déjà vécu des
scénarios comme celui-là où elle
reprendrait éventuellement demain matin
non je crois que je n'ai pas vécu ça je
je crois que c'était sous le mandat
précédent il avait eu sur un texte une
CMP qui avait été très longue du type 12
ou 15 je n'ai plus 9h la plus
longuequement la 9h la commission mixte
paritaire la plus longue c'est 9h oui et
et c'était c'est un cas relativement
exceptionnel parce qu'en général elle
dure j'ai j'ai vu descmp durer un quart
d'heure quasiment alors là c'est en cas
d'éche plutôt non en cas d'accord ou en
cas d'éche non non même en cas en cas en
cas d'accord voilà et en général c'est
1h 2h quoi voilà je je non je il
appartiendra au gouvernement de de
déterminer si effectivement la CMP doit
être suspendue et et reprise moi je je
pense compte tenu de l'agenda de cette
période de de de de de suspension des
des travaux parlementaires je je pense
que ça serait bien que cette question
soit en tout cas régler cette semaine
voilà c'est c'est je je l'ai dit dès dès
la semaine passée pour que dès la
rentrée nous puissions passer à d'autres
sujets il y a d'autres urgences au
niveau du du du pays et je crois que ça
apporterait de la sérénité je je je
souhaite finalement qu'il y ait une CMP
conclusive sur cette semaine très
rapidement Antoine léomand est-ce que la
gauche sort affaiblie finalement de
cette séquence je crois pas parce que
c'est nous qui avons battu cette ce
texte et que désormais il va y avoir une
clarification politique de toute façon
soit il y a pas de commission mixte
paritaire conclusive et il y a pas de
texte soit il y a une commission mixte
paritaire conclusive et donc vous nous
avez dit que les Français nous avez
appelé à travailler ensemble je crois
pas que vous nous ayez appelé à faire
des barrages républicains au deième tour
pour ensuite
intégrer la préférence nationale dans la
loi qui est dans le programme de Marine
Le Pen et par ailleurs je comprends pas
pourquoi le rassemblement national va
pas voter la loi alors que il va y avoir
dedans la préférence nationale et je ne
comprendrai pas que par exemple le modem
vote une loi qui est une une rupture
complète avec les propositions
principales du MoDem enfin je voudrais
juste dire un dernier point parce queon
a parlé du logement et des et des des
aides pour le logement supprimer les APL
égal créer des SDF mais si on veut
vraiment parler des des questions de
logement sachez quand même retenez ce
chiffre 3,5 % des propriétaires
détiennent 50 % des logements mis en
location je répète 50 % des logements
mis en location sont détenus par 3,5 %
des propriétaires encore une fois il y a
un problème de concentration bien votre
opposition en tout cas à ce texte on va
retrouver Elsa monagava qui se trouve
salle des qure colonnes Elsa on est
toujours suspendu à une éventuelle
reprise de la commission mixte paritaire
oui vous le voyez la salle des quatre
colonnes c'est un peu vidé des
journalistes mais vous enquiétez pas ces
journalistes ils vont revenir puisqu'on
annonce et bien une reprise normal de
cette commission mixte paritaire à 21h
il y a plusieurs scénarios possibles
soit on continue à discuter pour essayer
de trouver un accord même si on voit
cette question des aPL cristallise les
tensions entre la droite droite et la
majorité soit en acte qu'on est en
désaccord et dans ce cas on dit que la
commission mixte paritaire n'est pas
conclusive soit il y a une troisième
option on parle de peut-être suspendre
cette commission mixte paritaire le
temps de négociation mais nous à la
Chaîne Parlementaire on en a suivi
quelques-unes des commissions mixtes
paritaires c'est assez rare r quand même
de la suspendre peut-être peut-on le
faire quelques heures mais pas forcément
au-delà on devrait avoir plus
d'informations en tout cas autour de 21h
si cette commission mixte paritaire
reprend bien merci Elsa monagava merci à
tous nos invités d'avoir été ici sur ce
plateau et bien sûr à suivre en direct
sur LCP la conclusion de la commission
mixte paritaire sur le projet de loi
immigration on se retrouve sans doute un
petit peu plus tard dans cette
[Musique]
soirée